[Music]  you told me the story of the war when  the ground shook and the sky burn of the  ones that survived who will walk to a  different world where the powerful right  but that's not the way it has to be when  I found you a very human brain was  miraculously it's the loneliest feeling  not to know who you are in time you'll  remember  [Music]  Oh  Elita is new again it's harsh world down  here does that'll be willing to do what  it takes  [Music]  Michels she's the last of a kind  she contains technology that have been  lost for 300 years  let me show you something  [Music]  this body I feel a connection to it I  can't explain you know more about me  than you're saying if he does some  things have been and left forgotten and  I'll find out for myself  she's threatening the natural order of  things I need you to destroy her leader  they will come for you I'll have to face  them head-on  tonight is not a game  [Music]  [Music]  I'm with her